l'unesco tuttora sostiene che dopo la
lottizzazione di internet
la scoperta dell'intelligenza emotiva è
la più grande scoperta della dell'oggi
questo è mette insieme tutta una serie
di banalità che io ho cercato di
sintetizzare e che poi mi sono domandato
ma sono banalità che messe in un certo
modo danno veramente qualcosa di
fortemente innovativa tutti ci
ricordiamo quando i nostri insegnanti
avevamo iniziante preferito e studiavamo
quella materia perché gli insegnanti ci
piaceva e odiavamo la matematica perché
regolarmente la persona e faceva
matematica era insopportabile per vari
motivi comportamentali non legati alla
materia e questa banalità golem anche
stato il primo a affrontarla in modo
sistematico è diventata affascinante e
fortemente
vincente su molti campi inaspettati gol
ma non è stato quello che ha inventato a
che ha scoperto l'intelligenza emotiva
nasce in ambito accademico nasce cinque
anni prima
nasce in inghilterra ed è il primo però
che se n'è occupato al del duca tivo era
un corrispondente da new york times e
era appassionato da questa idea questa
idea si è trasferita anche su di noi
tutti abbiamo letto credo l'intelligenza
emotiva di conan e tutti ci siamo
appassionate qui l'idea perché un uomo
entra in una stanza trova la moglie con
un tra virgolette amico e spara questa
non è una domanda che tutti ci dobbiamo
porre è che non può essere cattiveria
bontà non può essere che avrà fatto non
va fatto succede qualche cosa che ci
sono voluti molti anni a capire succede
che i circuiti della intelligenza
emotiva vengono puntati completamente
saltati completamente azzerati
completamente
annullati dal cosiddetto furto hamid
d'aleo e dall'idea di goldman nasce
dalle lui scopre con i neurobiologi del
periodo del litio e novecento del bene
matisse latex e l'amigdala azzera le
influenze verticali e rende quell'uomo
in quel momento un animale del
paleolitico che usa le tecniche
difensive e aggressive dell'uomo che
oggi non esiste più
quindi da questa idea fondamentale nasce
tutto tutto lo studio e poi
successivamente è arrivato fino a
quest'altro pietra miliare che è la
strategia di apprendimento se diamo per
scontato che l'intelligenza emotiva
esista
piano piano arriveremo a calco oggetto
molto che questa capacità di
apprendimento e motivo può essere la
strategia vincente cioè quella prendiamo
emotivamente non ha paragone anche dal
punto di vista accademico con quello che
apprendiamo senza differenze emotive e
questa è una banalità che ci sono molti
15 anni per essere dimostrata e che è
dimostrata a livello di neuroscienze
cioè non è una idea una teoria
un'ipotesi
abbiamo le prove strumentali di questo
guardate questo encefalo studiato con
risonanze funzionale all'istanza
funzionale a una delle altre grandi
fantastiche e la digitalizzazione a ci
ha permesso di poter fare a misurare lo
spin tutti gli atomi del nostro
organismo e dividerli in modo funzionale
cioè provate a immaginare che è una cosa
veramente pazzesca e il solo
digitalizzazione e informatizzazione e
software hanno potuto permettere uno del
gene questo è un ceppo le studiato in
due momenti diversi una in un momento di
apprendimento e molto emozionale uno in
un momento di apprendimento non
emozionale come hanno generato
l'emozione ricercatori in modo più
banale facendo vedere un serpente e
facendo vedere un ragno la strana e
maggioranza
delle persone con un serpente velenoso e
un ragno velenoso si impaurisce a un
ritorno emozionale sul proprio in cielo
e si illuminano diciamo così alcuni
centri cerebrali
quando la stessa informazione è portata
senza associare il serpente e il ragno
si illuminano altre aree dell'encefalo
questo significa in modo
incontrovertibile che la emozione attiva
dei circuiti diversi da quelli dell'anno
ne emozione e la nostra corteccia è
quella ci dà poi le idee lavora in modo
diverso per cui la corteccia è
interessato dagli degli stimoli e delle
connessioni quando c'è un'emozione molto
diversa da quella non emozionale quindi
l'insegnante antipatico noioso che ci fa
latino senza dire niente di più attiva
delle aree encefaliche molto diversa
dell'insegnante sempre di latino ma
simpatico che sappia portare un
messaggio livello un pochino più
emozionale e sicuramente più
interessante su questa cosa nasce l'idea
dell'intelligenza emozionale e del
grande progetto del dell'apprendimento
emozionale viene sancito nel 2002
dell'unesco e si iniziano grande lavoro
di tutte le scuole di ordine e grado di
140 paesi
il
il primo grande lavoro scientifico
perché non vorrei parlare teoria ecco
non vorrei si parlasse di cose che si
pensa che no questo è un dato ormai
acquisito è assolutamente certo abbiamo
la prima meta analisi nel 2016 meta
analisi su 168 lavori selezionati su
tutta la letteratura mondiale quindi una
metanalisi importante dalla uil si è il
solito chicago e va sempre leader su
queste cose e l'università dell'inox
porto questo primo lavoro alla ribalta
poco dopo è l'altro grande cittadino di
chicago che obama decise dopo aver letto
questi lavori in modo decisamente
personalizzati ma tutti nel l'entourage
presidenziale quel momento erano
convinti di questo propone una legge per
cui in tutte le scuole statunitensi in
gran parte delle scuole sono intense
alcuni state ancora non lo hanno
malaffare nella maggioranza si è il
primo stato fu proprio quello delle
noise inserire nel piano formativo di
tutti i ragazzi la capacità di poter
interagire emotivamente con
l'apprendimento e si passa questo andato
duramente sul rivoluzionario dal
quoziente intellettivo che è un dato
veramente discutibile perché molte
aziende tuttora misurano il quoziente
intellettivo
io non sarei disponibile per esempio a
far misurare il quoziente intellettivo
con gli standard della della companies
del momento con un quoziente emozionale
che ha ben altro grado di complessità di
altre attento in queste cose perché
quando si è dato un etichetta una
persona un intelligenza con un numero
un'emozionalità con un numero quella
persona per tutta la vita è classificata
per modo e noi sappiamo che di
intelligenza ne abbiamo veramente tante
quindi sono cose molto pericolose però
diciamo che aver scoperto nelle emozioni
agiscono sulla corteccia e in che modo è
stata una grande
produzione subito appena questo
programma partita questa che è una
grande esperta di didattica negli stati
uniti disse ma voi volete condizionare
le mozioni siete de pazzi le emozioni
vanno scatenate non dobbiamo
assolutamente imparare a gestirle
dobbiamo farle uscire quindi il
dibattito nasce immediatamente e ognuno
poi la può pensare come come vuole
ovviamente
e allora noi in piccolo qui normalmente
con alcuni amici da tanti anni da una
quindicina d'anni stiamo provando a fare
una cosa e con harris venezia è più
volte parlato la maremma può essere una
fonte di emozioni per chi e per come lo
vedremo ma può essere un ambiente
particolarissimo dove far partire degli
input emozionali e arrivare a del delle
forme di apprendimento che sono state
strabilianti
abbiamo provato con tre ton con tre
esempi il primo è stato questo questo è
dell 87
chiedemmo alla comunità europea di
finanziarci tramite la regione toscana
il premio fu
ha segnato con i soldi di questo premio
sempre legato alla intelligenza
emozionale facemmo questo volumetto
questo volumetto lo abbiamo allegato a
questa rivista che allora nascente si
chiamava maremma chi vinceva il concorso
era un concorso a quiz chi aveva letto
il libretto era capito qualcosa risponde
va bene al concorso sulla rivista chi
vincerà il concorso della rivista tutti
i ragazzi delle varie scuole della
provincia vincere ma un viaggio di sette
giorni in barca a vela era legata al
mare questo tema mare ma intesa marina
marittima e in queste giorni dove non
succedere delle cose di questi sette
giorni e abbiamo imbarcato sei ragazzi
quattro sono rimasti talmente entusiasti
di quello è successo e sono rimasti nel
mondo del mare due non sono più voluti
venire al mare quindi molto pericolosa
gira su questi meccanismi è perché
l'aspetto emozionale può essere anche al
contrario
quindi se volete dare un'occhiata questi
sono solo dei sono rimasti e potete dare
un'occhiata a che tipo di metodologia
era stata usata è sì sì sì sì sì sono
assolutamente e fu un esperimento che ci
lasciò a bocca aperta nel senso eravamo
un chirurgo io quindi niente di
eccezionale un biologo marino
esperto velista un musicista è un
insegnante di lingue diciamo però una
linguista più che iniziate le lingue
quindi a livello accademico
provammo a questa cosa e rimanemmo a
bocca aperta
l'apprendimento dei ragazzi avevano
avuto su questa esperienza confinata su
una barca in condizioni veramente
pazzesca certi giorni veramente
pazzesche con dei test di ingresso dei
test di uscita furono notevolissimi
questi ragazzi aveva erano diventati tra
virgolette più intelligenti nel senso
avevano acquisito delle capacità dei o
ricche e accademiche non relazionali
particolarmente specifica e questo ci
lasciò a bocca aperta forse coleman
poteva avere ragione e ne abbiamo fatto
un altro
qualche anno dopo perché poi si deve
lavorare quindi il tempo è poco
però questa cosa ci continuava ad andare
[Musica]
attrarci diciamo intrigarci provammo un
altro progetto che è questo interfaccia
tra due mari questa è l'attimo fuggente
tra notte e giorno in un fondale sulla
spiaggia e il progetto era legata alla
situazione geografica della nostra zona
nostra zona è un'interfaccia una lingua
di terra tra due mari i lacustri hughes
che nel sesto secolo era
buffon seno marino pescoso e profondo e
il mare aperto che tuttora esistente
della cuspide sono rimaste delle tracce
delle memorie delle zone umide delle
paludi ma soprattutto del delle
situazioni l'interfaccia tra questi due
mari
per noi doveva creare una spiegazione
come mai in maremma la cultura marinara
non attecchisce
qui c'è il terrore del mare eccetera
normale del mare che è un problema
serissimo perché per terrore del mare
significa non avere tutti i benefit e
del mare tutte le innovazioni
tecnologiche vengono dal mare tutte le
idee nuove che vengono dal mare perché
perché il mare interno poi divento
palude e quindi malaria mortale al cento
per cento fino all'inizio del 1900 e
perché dal mare aperto arrivavano
abbiamo di fronte le baleari proprio
dritte sono dritte a noi corsica baleari
sono 150 miglia dritte il califfato
delle baleari che fino a tutto il 1700
invadeva tutti gli anni le nostre zone
portando la popolazione a zero quindi
sul mare qui non ci si poteva stare su
questa idea di base abbiamo fatto un due
itinerari e li abbiamo chiamati blu per
perdura essere un bel pepper ltd per
dare un'idea di start up e questa questi
due generale non sono itinerari a caso
ogni localizzazione di questo itinerario
questo è per la parte del mare interno e
questo coinvolge il mare esterno la
linea di costa è l'interfaccia questi
due itinerari dovevano stimolare la lato
emozionale del povero soggetto che
veniva che veniva a fare questo giro è
questo questa kharja diciamo facendo
questo giro a piedi in bicicletta e in
barca a vela apprendevano opzioni
accademiche in modo velocissimo tipo
inglese da regata è una delle cose più
noiose che esistano al mondo imparavano
tutto comprese le bandiere in brevissimo
tempo con lezioni frontali molto molto
veloci oppure botanica applicata oppure
per ente abbiamo fatto dei corsi molto
approfonditi
[Musica]
linguistica per archivisti quindi cose
anche particolarmente pesanti
il livello di apprendimento era un
livello importante ora io ho un minuto
non vi posso star elencare le tappe ma
ognuna di quelle tappe sono sicuro che
ognuno di voi vi farebbe scattare un
meccanismo emozionale magari non quello
giusto ma sicuramente un mettendo
nazionale e la metodologia è questa il
blu è quello che noi abbiamo
sintetizzato come emozionale quindi
l'ambiente la location la temperatura le
fioriture i profumi ma anche le cose
sgradevoli anche le paure anche la notte
alcune persone non hanno dormito per
mesi dopo aver fatto queste esperienze
perché non sappiamo poi bene quali sono
le paure in ognuno di noi sa e vanno
sapute prima perché se non sappiamo
prima
l'effetto è il contrario però
l'informazione rimane per sempre questo
è è sicuro anche l'informazione negativa
sono tutte banalità queste però se vi
faccio vedere quali poi sono i posti
vedrete che
è qualcosa di più il pepe era la parte
corticale quella e doveva essere
attivata dal blu dell'amigdala e del
nucleo striato e sono stati i corsi cosa
si poteva fare spazio a preparare un
impresa artica abbiamo provato a fare
cose sotto il ghiaccio con bambini per
esempio è stata una cosa molto
pericolosa ma che ha dato dei risultati
impressionanti non puoi entrare nei
singoli progetti perché ci vorrebbe un
giorno può essere però anche un
orientamento accademico un master di
secondo livello
il punto è farle insieme metterla
insieme queste cose e arrivare a un
qualche cosa possa avere anche un
successo economico
questa è la biografia di riferimento
alcuni posti velocissimamente perché
invece far vedere soprattutto uno li
conoscete tutti questi posti ma
mescolate e miscelati con delle
situazioni particolari e per esempio le
catacombe di che non sa sono una delle
cose più più spettacolari che si vanno
un posto di popoli nese è poi si entra
per cento metri sotto terra e siano le
più grandi catacombe d'europa dopo
quelle di roma e lì si creano delle
situazioni ovviamente suggestive su cui
è facile lavorare monte lista non se ne
parla ma presente anche la banale cala
piccola o russo vana vista in un certo
modo le location sono tutte particolari
ma più pazzesca e questo è qui concludo
questa è una zona
difficilissima individuali molti molti
anni per individuare la sua intendenza
la conosce è l'ultimo tempio templare
vicinissimo a roma perché siamo a meno
di 100 chilometri da roma siamo al
confine tra grosseto e viterbo scavato
in una delle zone più saga di tutta la
civiltà etrusca prestare al sancta
santorum dedicata alla colta la dignità
delle acque che per il mondo etrusco era
la più importante di tutte quindi alla
salute alla fecondità e le cose e scende
vitali su questo insediamento rupestre
nel 1300 se sono entrati nell'ultimo
numero solare dopo la famosa scomunica
che portò la fine del del gruppo
non voglio entrare in questa cosa per
quanto riguarda templari perché poi si
va nel già ridetto esoterico non
scientifico ma quello è impressionate il
posto siamo all'interno di un cono di
arenaria con tre sorgenti tre canali
d'acqua che vanno a concentrate su
queste norme monolite che al centro due
sono stati prosciugati alla
soprintendenza per salvare l'accesso al
tempio e uno è stato lasciato salendo si
entra in una chiesa del 303 mente
scolpita nella roccia e gli affreschi
sono l'ultimo esempio al mondo
gli affreschi di questa situazione tra
il pagano e il cristiano per questo che
scattò la scomunica il considerate che
non esistono più tempi di questo tipo
i simboli della fertilità femminile e
maschile la melograna il monolite su cui
sia l'accesso nascosto al tempio questa
location dove si può fare lezioni
frontali ma dove si può fare anche col
cappello la notte a una dormita e quando
vi alzate la mattina vi passano per la
testa cose completamente diverse da
quelle da serrano risiede addormentati
perché nessuno di noi può rimanere del
tutto indifferente a una storia di
questo tipo considerare questo posto è
stato salvato da o l'ignoranza culturale
dello sbarco degli americani perché
quando e qui chiudo durante la guerra
per senso cosa mi ha raccontato il
proprietario del terreno e sta al di
sopra quando durante la guerra durante
la ritirata dei nazisti un gerarca
nazista
si nascose dentro questo romitorio
perché è veramente introvabile
gli americani appena arrivati con
decisero con il ci fu uno scambio di
proprio di persone con il proprietario
di questo fondo il gerarca baby vendette
la propria vita dicendo dove erano
questi affreschi gli americani
arrivarono e portarono via tutta la
pasta fresca ta del romitorio sbagliando
obiettivo portarono via tutti gli atleti
del 400 che non avevano alcun valore di
unicità e lasciarono tutti quelli del
periodo templarios sono rimaste l'ultimo
al mondo quindi questo posto non può non
scatenare idee ma non ci interessa per
fare un giro turistico ci interessa del
parlare magari di informatica dei
sistemi o cose del genere
quindi l'obiettivo è l'apprendimento non
è il turismo questa è la bellissima
cantina di renzo piano dove anche qui
sono state fatte delle cose decisamente
splendide questo è la casa di richard
che ha attivamente un posto blu io lo
considero un posto dove possano venir
fuori delle idee non da poco quindi è
sicuramente una nostra parte la
bicicletta la mia la cambieremo in
quella a pedalata assistita
queste sono le varie è la conclusione
questa non arriviamo a questo tipo di
turismo non arriviamo a questo tipo di
applicazione del commercio inteso come
siamo sopra una cosa che ci può portare
avanti economicamente per decenni
sfruttiamola siamo sopra un tesoro no
non siamo sopra il tesoro siamo sopra un
bene
impagabile ma non ripetibile che se noi
trattiamo in questo modo
o come a venezia dove non vado più con
costa concordia entrano dentro in piazza
san marco noi tra poco perdiamo la
nostra identità e oltre che poveri
saremo anche disperati
[Applauso]